le conservatoire à nikki entre depuis
vingt ans au moins un cours par semaine
de la peinture de la poterie plus un
retour à ses premiers amours
c'est rare que je manque il faut
vraiment qu'ils et aux empêchements
pourquoi pour que le loupé le court je
veux pas trop réalisé que ça faisait
vingt ans nettement
c'est vrai que oui on dit toujours ça
passe vite mais c'est la vérité du fait
d'avoir fait ou quand même différent
puis tous les tous les ans en fait on a
d'autres sujets de ces jamais ennuyeux
on a toujours moi c'est toujours très
agréable de de pouvoir faire des
nouvelles choses annick fait partie des
580 élèves du conservatoire municipal de
cette saison 2017 18 disciplines y sont
proposés des disciplines qui change avec
le temps déjà il a 20 ans donc il a 20
ans je crois que c'est significatif de
tout l'attachement que porte la
population à ce conservatoire
quand on vit comme ça pendant une
vingtaine d'années et qu'on évolue et
qu'on suit un peu les mouvements
artistiques aussi c'est important au
niveau des cours qui sont mises en place
etc
je crois que l'important c'est
primordial au niveau de cette commune on
a plus de 500 élèves un conservateur est
donc un lieu d'enseignement destinés à
tous et dans un cadre de loisirs mais
qui peut devenir petit à petit un petit
peu plus que du loisir pour ceux qui le
souhaitent
donc forcément on va accueillir des
publics qui vont être débutant des
enfants et on va chercher à les
accompagner tout au long de leur
démarche artistique et répondre vraiment
à des questions qui vont être de plus en
plus pointues alors contrairement au
conservatoire de musique nous ne
passerons pas de diplôme enfin pour
passer d'une année sur l'autre
les tarifs débutent aux alentours de 110
euros pour une heure d'enseignement par
semaine
c'est ce professeur anime
quotidiennement les cours proposés
séverine enseigne la poterie la
céramique depuis sept ans j'ai cherché à
donner des cours mais qui ne soit pas
les cours dans un atelier voilà c'est à
dire qu'ici on a un public qui recherche
des choses plus spécifiques qu'un
atelier où chacun arrive avec ses
projets donc on travaille sur des thèmes
et des techniques en vue près de 40 %
des élèves sont des enfants les plus
jeunes ont cinq ans ça fait surtout gaz
penser que cge
j'ai fait un quart de de la vie qui met
du coup faire ma part